[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
pâques à puce ne vous trompez pas
compter bien sûr vous trois mois
d'attenté
il me manque bravo pâte à coeur quelle
voix magnifique
moi qui aime tant l'opéra je ne savais
pas où chantait si bien
ne soyez pas trop modeste si vous
chantez le grand air de carmen
je vous donnerai un sac de caramel qu'un
homme pas maintenant à tatort chantera
pour vous ce soir
si lens ne mange pas voir ce soir j'ai
un cousin violoniste à l'opéra de pata
ville je pourrais lui écrire et c'est
papa tard
enfin si ce n'est pas ma faute
le disque a rallié sac à papier
vous vous êtes bloqué deux mois je vais
vous expliquer monsieur bobos comment
vous avez rayer le disque par exemple
n'a pas du tout pathak heures cet
après-midi a pris froid et elle a perdu
sa voix et la peau possible petit si
nous ne voulions pas vous décevoir et
nous avons décidé d'utiliser le disque
alors pâte à coeur vous êtes aphone
parce que ça veut dire à fond ça veut
dire qu'on a plus de voix il faut
soigner ça vous m'entendez une si belle
voix promis des tisanes
dès qu'on prête compter sur nous
monsieur bourgault bon je vous pardonne
bonne nuit à minuit mais c'est un bon
teint une guérison subite
je suppose offre un miracle alors je
vais pouvoir entendre le grand air de
carmen turc un soulier ça peut marcher
[Musique]
l'amour est enfant d'avant
elle l'a jamais jamais être d'une loi
aura pas qu'un mais la console soit il a
laissé les caramels passivité l'amour
est enfant d'un pan am qui n'a jamais
jamais connu la loi on vient travailler
vous qu'il y ait de pata peluche qui ne
vous trompez pas monter bien sur vos
droits
il me manque
[Musique]